those people who don't know who having
been following this story there was a
letter circulated by a guy who's been
outed now our reg our researcher found
this guy he's an Elan pedophile we found
out his name who he was he has a degree
from Harvard he has I think of a
bachelor's in molecular biology and then
some kind of mechanical kinds of degrees
been published in peer-reviewed journals
moderate leftist he decided to circulate
kind of his Jerry Maguire moment up a
reasonable memo to Google so we had that
we can bring it up so his memo basically
talked about this idea of diversity
hiring for the sake of diversity and he
was saying hey you know what we may
actually we may actually be sort of
countering our own goals here it may
sound counterintuitive but instead of
just hiring women for the sake of women
maybe we need to appeal to them or
actually value traits that we tend to
find on average more in women like being
more cooperative more balanced home and
work life as opposed to Silicon Valley
status that sounds like common sense he
went out of his way yeah people who
don't know this is why this is important
and we'll go into transition to YouTube
he went out of his way with this letter
to take some digs at right-wingers on
climate change on issues he went out of
his way to throw him some bones and said
listen I was way to specifically say I'm
not exclusively against diversity no
saying this is how we might better
achieve diversity including political
and moral diversity and actually
provided some steps to take that could
be productive to be included by the way
in a multi-pronged approach from Google
please go read the whole letter for
context the point is this it couldn't
have been more polite and the response
the response from Google it's so funny
feel like these are not Google's values
these do not represent what and then you
have all these private letters
circulating among Google from of course
the people who screamed a lot as this
makes me feel unsafe in this work
environment diversity is of the utmost
importance so up by the way interesting
enough there was a 50 per no poll at
Google showed about 50% almost half of
people either agreed or somewhat agreed
or didn't think the letter was so
harmful that I needed to be you know
excoriated the way it was so that shows
you internally no one wants to speak up
about it
yeah yeah but my point here is this if
this letter okay which is as incredibly
civil
reasonable productive not just like
Jonna Oliver will talk about later is
saying that's bad you suck actually
saying hey these could be some steps
that in tandem with what you're doing
might make us more efficient if this is
treated as though it's not see hate
speech propaganda me is [ __ ] Bay no I
haven't got a shot the point is none of
us have a chance so that sort of
transitions to YouTube YouTube released
some new guidelines people are afraid of
it we told you we had a secret meeting
secret meeting we have private meeting
with with some pretty high up I guess
executives was a Putin with Russia and
their subsidiary of Google and a lot of
you been asking for questions so we've
been trying to work on some issues with
with our channel and also get some
answers for conservatives so in the
spirit of actually trying to be
productive and offer solutions I think
there are some things that YouTube
specifically could do to fix its problem
with conservatives because I'm sure
YouTube doesn't want to piss off half of
all the audience right they've got to
understand that it's going to be
self-defeating at some point and include
conservatives so here are some things
that we think could be done with YouTube
even its current in its current state to
appeal to both sides again if we're
actually looking to live together if
we're actually looking to find common
ground so let's see if leftists can
agree on this number one I think YouTube
could improve its advertising algorithms
so this is something you know they say
oh advertisers are pulling out they
don't want to be associated with
controversial content now they're
necessarily defined controversial
content this is controversial content
that letter to Google it's controversial
content here's the thing as one of the
biggest tech companies in the world just
fixed yeah guess what their sponsors out
there who would pay a premium to be
associated with this kind of content
whether it's you know firearm
manufacturers you don't allow Smith &
Wesson could be USC CA I've seen Prager
you advertisements there are plenty of
conservatives who would rather run on
this video or just free speech advocates
who'd rather run on this video but half
the time people watching this channel
see ads for Muslim singles or gay
cruises I always say well it's just the
algorithm so how about you make the
algorithms a little smarter biggest tech
company in the world you'll make more
money and you don't have to worry about
advertisers pulling out the advertisers
pulling out or people who don't who
don't support the idea of free speech
anyway or they're offended by a letter
like this there are plenty of people who
would pay more you
more money we make more money the
audience doesn't have to be divided
number two I think the restricted mode
algorithms yeah could be fixed this is
something we've been dealing with
talking with YouTube behind the scenes
and you can see the lights kind to go on
again if you're the biggest tech company
in the world and what little strictmode
is all an algorithm I think it's 20
something out of six hundred something
videos in our channel are not restricted
but Young Money jay-z The Young Turks
where everything is fun word this N word
that it's allowed sorry not get behind
the center button but again how about
this if you're the smartest tech company
in the world create algorithms or have
if you have to have some people might
God manually going and fix it value
context over content that way in that
case you don't get something like face
down ass up that's the way I like to hmm
be unrestricted and monetized in our
video sitting down with a man who works
for care titled man who works for care
finds Hamas ties gets restricted and D
monetized again the context over content
is what should matter and if you to Vout
so right away number one you'll make
more money and you'll appeal to
advertisers more number two you'll
appeal to the viewers more you'll create
a better viewership experience and if
your goal is actually just restrict
content that kids shouldn't be seeing
you'll be more effective at doing so
don't rely on YouTube heroes and their
mass flagging program number three
trending content now we've been told
that trending content is all algorithmic
obvious I don't know about that I I find
it odd that I always see Samantha bee
and John Oliver and Keith Olbermann and
trending content and I'm not watching
always and it's always so few plays
generally when you see the few plays few
likes few comments I don't know one
understands the algorithm you can't
explain why you take it for the
announcement videos take it from his
iPhone literally and that redhead trend
got 10 trends like 2000 people have seen
it will they say that's because that's
what you're watching so let's say it's
algorithms okay but they're all there is
curated content on YouTube YouTube
spotlight you saw with heroes YouTube
global diversity program so how about
this YouTube whoever is curating your
content where someone is there's there's
a human interaction there just make the
liberal bias 5 to 1 yeah in other words
right now I will see 9
- 15 pieces of far-left content for
every one piece of conservative content
if that and it's very rare it usually
has to be so blatantly news breaking
that's something James O'Keefe did or
something that happened on television
that's a viral video that they just
can't ignore it but it is so I'm not
saying make it one to one that would be
nice wouldn't it five to one doesn't
five to one guess what conservatives
won't come in and won't think that
you're trying to get rid of them in
tandem again with this letter and people
at Google excoriating a man saying hey
maybe we should look at biological
differences between men and women can
you see why they maybe think that you
don't want them there when you add all
these things up right now a conservative
comes here to YouTube they go to my
video they see an advertisement for
Muslim singles they see it it's
restricted they have to sign in and of
course it's pindy monetize and they go
trending content see Samantha pee and
keep open even though it all has 85
thousand plays did you see what they
think the system's rigged
I can't hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside